احد ابرز ميزات التسوق عبر الانترنت
والارجاع المجاني او الفيو ترنس لكن هذا
قد يصبح من الماضي الجميل
شركات التجزئه اكتشفت ان المتسوقين اعتدوا
على طلب احجام والوان وعندما تصل يختلون
واحده او اثنتين فقط ويعيدون الباقي معدل
ارجاع المشتريات عبر الانترنت وصل الى 21%
في امريكا ارتفاعا من 18 في المئه عام
2020 وهذا يؤدي الى خسائر كبيره ليس فقط
بسبب تكلفه استعاده البضائع ايضا ضائعه
فرصه بيعها خليل ولذلك بدات شركات التسوق
الالكتروني بفرد رسوم على رد البضائع غير
المرغوب فيها على الرغم من انها خطبه
محفوفه بالمخاطر وقد تؤدي الى خساره
الزبائن
شركات الكبرى بدات تطبق رسوم رد المشتريات
مثل زورومي انفيتش وابوهو
في امريكا ارتفع عدده تجار التسجيل الذين
فرضوا رسومات على رد المشتريات من 31% الى
40 في المئه وفقا لبحث اجرته شركه
مساله وقت حتى يقتل الاخرون في الاتجاه
نفسه فاذا تمكنت زواره من فعل ذلك فيمكن
اي شركه القيام بذلك ايضا
[موسيقى]